here's my wife with 9x I do okay
excellent
now what you can see here is different
to what you drew in a couple of ways the
first way is I asked you to do a
restriction on the domain I asked you to
grow from naught to 2pi that's a domain
and the range is negative 1 to 1 I asked
you to go from naught to 2pi where it is
2pi by the way on here ya big after 6
because pi is 3.14 ish so pi is 6.28
there it is right there you can see my
intercepts okay now what I'd really love
to be able to do is see this with all of
the radians sort of easier to read it is
in radians right now but come over to
the top right hand corner if that's
where you've got that little arm wrench
icon into the settings you can see
radians is highlighted have you got that
there should already have come default
right what I want you to do is it's
small I apologize go to where it says
step do you see there's on an X and a
y-axis and each one is a step when they
say step what they mean is you know how
many numbers are there between each of
the gridlines that's what they're
talking about what I want you to do is
on the x axis for the x axis step you
can either type in the letters P I or if
you put the desmos keyboard is a PI
right here and I'm going to change the
step to PI on two I think it actually
defaults to that so you can see now
everything's in vidiians did it come up
on yours so we're gonna get excellent
fantastic all right now this is more
useful to me now what we're going to do
is we're going to investigate this guy
and try and work out together how we can
express the derivative off of just a
visual investigation of this now what I
want you to do in your book if you
haven't already I haven't so probably
you have another please make a heading
which is calculus of trigonometric
functions I pick you poke yeah basically
we are going to do more than just
treating metric functions but that's
where we're gonna start today we're
gonna be in this little land for a
little while so this is an appropriate
Haven I think
now what I want us to do is to kind of
and we're going to gather our evidence
gather clues by looking at different
parts of this graph and trying to
understand features of it and we're
gonna kind of we're trying to gather
information about this individual
function we can conclude different
things about its derivative okay
now you will have already even
encountered maybe you just will stick
into something a textbook or something
other you 1200 students showed you they
already know what the derivative of this
function is and I'm not interested I
need to know this you know why it is
what it is the answer is actually much
less important to me okay
this graph unlike say y equals x squared
or those other graphs that we start a
different chain before it repeats over
and over again right
what collapse when the function repeats
over and over and over again we call
this the paper again and it's it's got a
sort of resistance it's the same a
periodic function right
just like the periodic table it's the
same idea over and over again the same
properties and chemicals right so it's a
periodic function now walking back
thanks so miss to you it's if stuck with
it okay now figure out this is me right
if if our function that we're actually
interested in if this thing is periodic
then the gradient function of this
surely that must be periodic too right
so that makes sense like for example
you've got some points here that are
very important is it working you got
some point here that are really
important and they're going to come up
over and over and over again right so
therefore we what we can say is this is
about the derivative of sine X that's
what we're investing right now because
sine X is periodic then surely the
derivative of sine X is also periodic so
that's our first clue okay that's the
first thing the second thing is when it
comes to gradient a few of the spots on
this graph are more important and more
interesting and easier to spot than
others I'm going to zoom out I'm going
to try and keep this in a stable spots
that we do
now with this in mind for example let's
mark them in right now I'm gonna yeah we
have games these spots here and here and
here what do we call these guys with
some stationary points why do we call
them stationary points yeah they're kind
of not moving right the technical
definition is if we were to draw a
tangent line at these spots the tangent
would look like this right these
particular spots you get now what does
this tell us about the derivative what
do you know about the derivative the
derivative right the derivative actual
I'm just gonna write dy DX because I am
lazy do you want the X back it's gonna
be zero when X takes on a bunch of
particular value so we can see some of
them right here what's the first one
that marked in have a look the x value
high on two very good
what's the next one three PI on to
what's the next one five point two and
in fact every odd value of pi on two in
the positive direction in fact also in
the negative direction so I could have
had a dot dot dot the beginning here is
negative two right so all of these just
minus sign on it and you also get these
stationary points okay very good now the
next thing I want Rodrigue is and it's a
bit tricky to do some screen that's why
I also draw sine X building on the graph
that you drew on your page what I want
you to is attack something we've done
before which is to talk about not just
these places where the derivative is
zero but I want us to think about the
sine the plus or minus of the derivative
here so for example see this spot right
here it's increasing your gray it's
increasing the right there so I can put
a plus sign there showing that I should
have a positive gradient to match that
increasing part of the function
and it's still positive it's still
positive and so on I want you to start
marking in those in and you've also got
these negative sections yeah how's your
drive okay I'm going to put this back in
a second but here's one I prepared
earlier now what have you got here all
the parts where it's going down all
parts going up the sign of the
derivative that's what we've just
determined right we're gonna try and
graph this derivative I want to know
where is it positive where is it
negative so the orange parts it's all
negative the green part it's all
positive so you might want to indicate
that you know with something like this
do you RDX somewhere it's zero where are
you Martha's in but sometimes it's
greater than zero it's positive in those
particular sections and sometimes it's
negative so you can put that draw that
on to your graph okay
where is it positive where is it
negative